في البدايه صحيه ومختلفه كثيرا الكثير منا
يمشي حافيه القدمين في المنزل بحكم العاده
لكن هل تعلم عزيزي المشاهد وهي عادل ان
هناك يوم عالمي للسير حافي القيء القدمين
اسمه
كل سنه اول يوم من يونيو يتم تشجيع الناس
على ترك احذيتهم والسماح لاقدامهم بالتنفس
يعني باختصار هناك شيء من الشفاء في
المشيء من دون حذاء بالفعل دراسات جديده
اوضحت فوائد صحيه غير
رابطه اخصائيه لعلاج الطبيعي في المانيا
قالت ان المشي باقدام حافيه يوميا يساهم
في وقايه الانسان من الاصابه بتشوهات
القدم دراسه اخرى يا راويه اجرها اطباء
متخصصون في الطب الرياضي اظهرت ان المشي
باقدام حافيه يعزز النمو البدني والدماغي
عند الاطفال حتى التخلص ايضا من القلق
والتوتر والارق كلها فوائد من المشي من
دون حذاء تخيلوا انا مش عارف ليش بعدنا
لابسين حذاء تدرين شلون انا ما بحب امشي
حافيه نهائيا وبتضايق
قدميك تتنفس
هلا بعد الحلقه بنطلع حفيظ
عن الفوائد
ربما لاحظتا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اليوم حول المشي حافي القدمين كيف لا فهو
اليوم العالمي للسير حافي القدمين المعروف
باسم جوبر فوداي
جوبر فوداي هو احتفاله سنوي وقاموا في
الاول من يوليو من كل عام يتم تشجيع الناس
على خلع احذيتهم والسماح لاقدامهم بالتنفس
واخذ الوقت للمشي او الجري حافي القدمين
قدر الامكان تمت صياغه الفكره في عقاب
كارثه تسونامي التي حدثت منذ اكثر من 15
عاما وادت الى تضرر الكثير من الناس
واغراقهم في الفقر فتمت الدعوه لهذا اليوم
لمساعده هؤلاء الناس قدر الامكان والتبرع
بالاحذيه التي يمكن توزيعها على المحرومين
للمحتاجين الى احذيه سواء كانت جديده او
حتى مستعمله
منذ انشاء هذا اليوم تم التبرع بحوالي 19
مليون زوج من الاحذيه على مستوى العالم
ولا يزال يوم جورج يحتفل به في العديد من
البلدان حول العالم والعديد من الدراسات
اظهرت فوائد صحيه ممتازه للقيام بذلك على
كل حال سال الناس في السعوديه وطلبنا من
البعض الاشخاص المشي حافيا في المكان
المخصص لذلك وسالناهم عن رايهم في التجربه
نتابع
[موسيقى]
اسفه اشياء كثيره
تغير عندي شلون روتين اليوم بالبيت خلاص
صرت على طول يعني ابي امشي على طول يعني
لو اليوم امشي احس بنقص المتعارف علياء
انه الافضل طريقه او افضل وقت الواحد يمشي
على الممشى الصحي طبعا بعد اداء المجهود
الرياضي
الممشى الصحي طبعا او المشي حافي القدمين
بيعمل على استشفاء العضله بقوي مفاصل
القدم امشي
هنا صرنا اذا ما طلعنا البر ورحنا المارس
الرياضه هنا لها فوائد عظيمه وانا انصح
الجميع بالتعامل مع الممشى من ناحيه
الرياضه النظافه لاهتمام شيء يعني لا يوصف
احنا علاج طبيعي ننصح الاهالي دائما
يوجهون الاطفال بالمشي في الممشى الصحي
ذلك مما يعزز قوه العضلات عند الاطفال
خصوصا في هيكله القدم يمنع كذلك القدم
المتسطحه
استقامه الساقين
[موسيقى]
طيب من بيروت تنضم الينا مدربه اليوغا
نادين خليل نديم صباحك سعيد وان كان يعني
انا قاعد اسمع كاظم الساهر يغني حافيه
القدمين لماذا نمشي حفاه صباح الخير صباح
الورد صباح الخير
انا اليوم احب احكي عن الارسن داي او
ممارسه المشي حافيه القدمين مع اتصال
مباشر بالارض
وحابه يخبر قديش هيدا الموضوع عنده منافع
عديده للجسم ان كان على
الجرس او حتى على الرمل بالبحر
ازهرت الابحاث المكثفه
عندما تتلاقى كضميكا
تتلامس مباشره بالارض
منافع عديده منها اللي بصير انه الجسم
ببلش
الكترونز
نيجاتيفلي تشارج اليكترونز من الالكترونات
بس حتى نحكيها بالعربيات سلبيه من الارض
من طاقه الارض وهني
زي اكلايك انت اوكسدنس
الجسم بهذه الطاقه
مضادات اكسده بتعزز الجسم بهذه المضادات
الاكسده وببلش يتفاعل وهون في عده منافع
منها والاهميه نزع سبب الالتهابات بالجسم
او حتى التخلص منها كليا وحتى انه تقلل من
طيب ناديه معلش لانه وقتنا ضيق ضيق وانا
حابه اخد منك معلومات اكثر بتقولي انه
ممكن المشي سواء كان على الرمل او على
التراب العادي او على الارض العاديه مفيد
ولكن مثلا انت واقفه هلا وفي يمكن حجار
على الارض طب ما هذا ممكن يؤذي القدمين
يؤدي الى تلف جلد القدمين يعني انا واحده
من من الاشخاص ما بحب المشي حافيه بصراحه
لهذا السبب
عالرمل ممكن ولكن على ارض مثل اللي انت
واقفه عليها كثير صعب
هيدي الارض كلها تراب وكلها ورق شجر البحث
اللي فيها كتير قليل حتى ما بيزعج حتى
بتكوني عم بتحسي عم تعملي تدليك للقدم هلا
بالنسبه انه بتزعج الجلده بتعرفي دايما
فينا نتعامل مع الجلده بالكريمات بس
الاهميه يلي هون هو اهم بكتير من انه
الجلده انا كنت سبق وقلت على صفحتي
عن اهميه هذا الموضوع كله قديش مفيد جدا
حتى هو بخفف من الالم اذا اشخاص موجوعين
اذا ظهروا مشوا بيخفف من الالم يعني عنده
منافع عديده منها ضغط الدم منها الدوره
الدمويه بنشطها
باذكار سيستم
اذا تكرمت سنين بيقولوا انه القدم باطن
القدم هو بنك الاعصاب او مركز الاعصاب
اليوم حينما نمشي
كم الفتره اللي نمشيها حتى
نتبادل هذه الطاقه مع الارض ومن الممكن ان
تتعادل مع اجسامنا وتخرج الطاقه السلبيه
ونكسب هذه الفوائد كل يوم قديش بدنا نمشي
لا يقل عن 20 دقيقه ولكن عشرين دقيقه هي
كفيله بانك انت الجسم حتى الايدين اذا ما
بدك تحط رجلك على الارض فيك الايدين او
حتى فيك تحط ايديك على الشجر اي شيء
بالطبيعه ممكن يعطيك هل هل شاحنات يلي
مضاده للاكسده لتتفاعل مع جسمك من 20
دقيقه واذا كان اربعين دقيقه الجسم عم
يمتسطا اكثر واكثر واحسن فاذا لمده عشرين
دقيقه كل يوم نحن للاسف بهذا العصر ما عنا
بقى تلامس مثل قبل بالزمانات مع الارض قبل
كانوا يتفاعلوا
يزرعوا اكلاتهم يتفاعلوا اكثر مع الارض
يتلمسوا اكثر مع الارض نحن اليوم عم نلبس
باجرينا اشياء عم تعمل بلوك لهل طاقه يلي
نحن لازم نشرجها من الارض نادين نشكرك
جزيل الشكر الحقيقه على انك رحتي على هذا
المكان الجميل في هذا الصباح
وعرفتينا يعني فعلا
جميله جدا وانك عرفتينا على فوائد المشي
حافي القدمين ومعلش يعني اعذرينا انه
شلحناك من اجلك ومشيتي
بس بالشتاء الصيف صعبه بالخليج صعبه عنا
نمشي حابين
انا على طول بتابع هذا الموضوع يعني انا
في شغله نحن على طول حافيين القدمين
بالتدريب اليوغا شكرا جزيلا يعطيك العافيه
يا نديم وان شاء الله نشوفك بمواضيع اخرى
يعطيك الف عافيه لم
تابعه يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات